oh look blew these up hey for one second
he's waking up he's trying to move
around
movies are big business but there are
only 13 astonishing genres humans now
watch so many movies that action
adventure comedy Drama Fantasy
historical horror musical Noir romance
science fiction Thriller and Western
aren't enough to hold people's interest
will and Chad you must create a new
genre that will be proprietary for the
dude's e-plus streaming service this is
genre Genesis begin
doozy has been threatening to start a
doozy plus streaming service and now we
have to come up with a new a new genre
do you I mean I don't know the movie
genres are fun how difficult that that
task yeah that's a weird one uh a new
genre of film
you know or television for that I will
say this I believe there is kind of a
new genre it's not new but I think there
is an I will say an unrecognized genre
in movies and it coincides with
something that is very popular online I
am of course talking about cringe cringe
cringe I think that that is now a viable
genre of film
um I would argue that you know you can
go back and look at like Ed Wood and the
kind of B sci-fi horror movies of the
50s and 60s as maybe where it started
these kind of unintentional attempts at
something interesting that wound up
being shitty and you can follow that all
the way through to like Troll 2 the best
worst movie ever there's a whole
documentary made about that that was a
movie that was made and I believe the
early 90s late 80s maybe but I think you
come to the room
which was 2001 or 2002 Tommy wiseau's uh
Opus he wrote it he directed it he's in
it oh hi Mark that one yeah I did not
hit her I didn't think oh hi Mark this
is a very important movie and I'm my
best customer
got that scene you're my favorite
customer yeah hello hi doggy hi doggy um
that movie I think a lot of people like
it has become what it's become its own
thing for sure and I think at this point
in media it's kind of passe to even be
like oh I like the room or whatever but
that movie really was in my opinion the
crossing of the line between we can
accept that some movies are bad and we
laugh at them sometimes too this is a
[__] phenomenon and it is an
important piece of media because it
really outlines that now is a movie
watching audience we can be just as
entertained by something that is
actively bad because we know that it
should be good we know what narrative
structure should be we know what acting
should be and if it's the opposite of
that in just the right way we can be
equally entertained well you're talking
about something that is all over the
place that's a lot of fun to watch stuff
like that yeah you know what uh Molly
and I watch every Christmas it's our
little tradition we watch cats yeah
movie that's a huge huge uh piece of
cringe absolutely that film came out
2019 and we I remember we went to the
movie theater we were in Vancouver and
uh we watched that movie we watch it
every uh a year around Christmas or
actually I should say we watch parts of
it because it's it's it's not it's not
um it's not a very good movie no it's
terrible yeah it's a bat it was it was a
very interesting misfire and one that
people thought that the makers of
thought would be an Oscar winner the
makers everybody in it Jennifer Hudson
that movie definitely is like I'm gonna
win a [__] Oscar you know they're all
swinging for look let me let me say
something about uh filmmaking someone
once said making a film is like going
into a closet with no lights on uh
getting dressed coming out and saying
how do I look
pretty good yeah it's good it's a good
one um you know it's hard to know when
you're making a movie and I do see the
actors struggling a bit because they
thought they were going to have paws on
their hands they thought CG was gonna I
mean they're they're acting opposite a
[__] tennis ball on a c-stand they
don't know what the hell's going on and
then you've got you know people doing
cat [__] with their hands in these
little paw things Judy Dench exposes her
cat vagina in one scene I'm sorry what
was that I've seen this movie four times
it's when Ian you've seen it four times
well I've seen it every Christmas I
might have seen it a few more
Jesus four times
[__] cough genius not a cat's genius
cough genius I watched that movie the
week it came out I would say probably 20
times now you did not I went to the
[__] ArcLight with a notebook that I
bought specifically for the purpose of
taking notes during every scene by
myself I'm sitting there in the dark
just
scribbling away people are looking at me
on either side like what the [__] is
this Maniac doing probably fearing for
their lives
um that movie needs to be studied and so
I studied it let me tell you
foreign
it's true you [__] went you did not
watch this movie 20 times at least I've
probably seen it a hundred times dude I
know you have not yes I have dude I
would have known that if you went and
saw cats uh if you've seen cats 100
times I've probably seen it that much
there are a bunch of movies that I have
seen that's a full-time job hey forget
about nothing forever it's Cats Forever
yeah I'm watching that I'm watching I'm
living in that world it's one of my
favorite movies and and the Judy Dench
exposing her vagina happens when Ian
McKellen is on stage delivering his
final performance when they're trying to
figure out which cat is going to go to
the heavy side layer yeah she likes it
so much at a certain point they cut to
her Judy Dench this is Dame Judy Dench
in cat ears is sitting in a cat bed
laying down in Repose and she hikes one
leg up to expose her vagina to Ian
McKellen I don't think that that's why
she is that why she did that yes I don't
remember that part but you've seen the
movie a hundred times do you remember
Taylor Swift I remember Taylor Swift do
you remember yourself yes I remember
Idris Elba was actually he kind of kind
of comes out on a cavity unscathed yeah
what
laughs
oh my [__] god dude four times this
is what four times the viewing again
it's a rough watch but I see but but I I
it's it's a rough watch all around if
you haven't seen cats the movie we could
[__] on cats this is a podcast dude
happened there's no rumor that there was
a butthole cut of cats that they had to
they put CGI buttholes on the cats why
not to remove them yeah but yeah they
went over budget because they did things
like spending 125 000 on cat buttholes
yeah and then had to uh Move the cat
bottles which cost 250 000 but cringe is
a good uh that's a good genre I have
another genre that I'm thinking of
please for for because I I've noticed
this and we've talked about it on the
show Megan the movie Megan tweet which
dudes he had us watch was uh I mean it
made me laugh did it not make you yeah
dude it's hilarious I love that [__]
movie it's a funny any [__] movie uh
Barbarian which we both watched
coincidentally that's a a horror movie
that is also has some really funny stuff
in it and I think that com it's hard now
to uh put a traditional Studio comedy
movie sort of what is what what we've
considered to be comedy through the you
know influenced by the 80s but through
the 90s and early 2000s it's hard to get
a movie like that in the movie theaters
I think it's changing do you think it's
changing you've seen this trailer for
this Tony Collette movie called I think
it's called Mafia mama no I love Tony
Collette it looks [__] great what she
thought she's just like a kind of I
think like Suburban House mom and she
finds out that her secretly her father
was the head of this [__] Italian
mafia family he dies she becomes the
head of this Italian mafia family yeah
but that's a lot like that that that's a
very 80s 90s movie premise that's what
I'm saying I think that shit's coming
back hold on a second dude good well
hold on dude hold on Chad just hold on
dude okay
I'm holding oh
hold on dude okay
yeah hold on dude I here's something I
wanna
hold on dude hold on a second brother
Chad says here's something that's new
dude because dudes he wants us to do the
doozy show brother and Will's over here
saying I'm free will it was just two
dudes [__] around and dudes he says
no dude do what I say talk about a new
movie genre but then what Chad hold on
dude then what Chad hold on dude then
what Chad does dude is he says here's a
movie with Tony Collette Brother Where
and then he lays out something that
would be basically you'd see in the 90s
brother and that's a different time dude
which means it already happened brother
and we're trying to come up with a new
genre dude so let me tell you something
Chad
well if I may
if I may brother fool yourself just in
the middle of this if I may I think that
you know these movies that are horror
based something Horrible's [__]
happening uh
uh you know off the air earlier you told
me you went and saw that new M Night
Shyamalan movie yeah right and what'd
you think it's a
D Plus for me okay that's very that's a
diplomatic score for that film but what
I would like to say is you know what's
missing from knock at the cabin
some comedy now what would you what
would you call a comedy under those
circumstances something like Barbarian
which you need to go see what's a
spoiler alert there's some people
underneath in the Subterranean part of a
home there's cages there's crazy [__]
going on and it's it's very it's hellish
here's the new the new genre I think
tromedy what do you think of that I like
it yeah so it's it's [__] that should
ruin your [__] life it's it's themes
about someone who's you know being
chased by a [__] murderer or
something like that they're locked in
the basement or something but there's
funny elements some of the stuff that
that the actor who played the the lady
under the house there had with uh Justin
long and the other actor actor whose
name I'm forgetting who is she I can't
remember her name
um uh anyway
we're hilarious yeah Megan was hilarious
yeah I mean he's a killer I like the the
name tromedy I have not heard that but I
you know comedy horror or horror comedy
those are sub-genres that are recognized
dramedy the new genre yeah if I'm if I
may dude for doozy plus is in my opinion
it's stuff that is straight up traumatic
and that's where the comedy starts it's
a story about a you know uh dude he's
just trying to get across get get along
in this world he's got a new job at the
business and he's a businessman right
and then
something traumatic happens in the first
[__] scene then the rest is a comedy
brother
I like weird genre switch things I think
that's going to be very big coming right
around the corner okay so what do we got
for doozy plus then what do we think I
don't know I would watch a 24-hour
cringe stream for sure but I mean the
difference between well this is cringe
and Camp is important to recognize
sometimes you're making a movie
specifically to kind of live in that
like this is intentionally bad like a
Sharknado or that there's that movie
cocaine bear coming out I think that's
an attempt at camp where you realize
that the premise is crazy you give the
tight it's a crazy title that is Camp
that is not cringe cocaine bear cringe
is when you're trying to hit something
else a different Target and you miss
completely because it is so [__] bad
like cats was really an attempt at a big
oscar-winning like Broadway musical
movie like uh Les Mis like a [__] uh
what was the Moulin Rouge [__] like that
yeah do you remember movies do you
remember Karnak the Magnificent
no what the [__] is that Johnny Carson
used to do that bit with Ed McMahon oh
yes yes Karnak was the the the uh he put
on the turban and put on the wacky
future casting Coke cocaine bear cocaine
bear cocaine bear cocaine bear
what is
James
corden's nickname
cocaine bear is that what you're wanting
from I'm not trying to spread a rumor I
don't know anything about James Corden
he's in cats and he's [__] on cats as
soon as the movie came out and started
getting panned he immediately was like I
don't know [__] this movie he like uh
cut ties with it that's your best
impersonation I've ever seen can you do
that again
I don't know [__] it yeah [__] this
movie I'm James Corden yeah give me some
cocaine I'm James Gordon where's the
cocaine I'm a I'm a fluffy fella I'm the
cocaine bear says comic got some good
podcasts hey we're having a good time
here on
thank you moving on well we almost got
we almost got a [__] genre for Duty
it's either cringe [__] somehow yeah
it's Johnny Carson has Karnak predicting
that James Corden will even exist at
that point and also be called the
cocaine yeah May a diseased Yak take up
residence in your station wagon
please
[Music]
do do
oh